photographs and videos show the
devastating toll of harvey on texans one
of the most memorable images though is
from a nursing home we all remember this
picture of the resident sitting in
waist-deep water it spread very quickly
online and not long after another
picture showed the residents safe and
dry at another facility jamie yuka spoke
to one of the women in the original
picture she's in dickinson southeast of
houston jamie good morning
good morning the name of the small
nursing home is la vita bella which
means the beautiful life in italian but
life became unbearable for the residents
here when flood waters came rushing into
the home during hurricane harvey we
spoke with former resident ruth miller
she recounted what happened
can you tell me about being in the water
i like it you didn't like it
it's scary
yeah
i love your safe as the water rose
around ruth miller and her friends the
64 year old says staffers at lavita
bella relied on a simple mantra
keep calm and collected
do they just keep saying that over and
over again
keep calm and collected so that's fine
oh smells good doesn't it nursing
homeowners trudy and pete lamson say
they were initially told to shelter in
place that is where the water rose in
this room but evacuation was soon their
only option within about 45 minutes to
an hour it went from ankle
to stomach to get help trudy snapped
this photo of residents in rising water
and sent it to her daughter in florida
i told my daughter do what you have to
do a few hours after the image was
posted on social media came the rescues
then the reunions
what was it like when you first saw me
today oh
it was
happy ruth is now living with her older
sister susan baubrick when you look at
that picture again what goes through
your mind how tragic this could have
ended up
i think the water level rose there and
it and luckily it held
it held
ruth will stay with her sister until the
family can find a new facility to fit
her needs as for the owners of the
nursing home they plan to rebuild but
you can see there's plenty of damage
outside as well as inside so there's no
telling when residents would be able to
return here maurice okay jamie thank you
you could feel their gratitude but let's
let's hear for social media all right a
few hours that's right and these folks
were rescued in a way that wasn't
probably possible or likely years ago
and we got to see that story from
beginning to end and there was a happy
ending there very very